hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash popcorn box candy wrappers they
all taste so good instead of throwing
your trash on the floor won't you please
give it to me
thank you for considering your fellow
patrons ladies and gentlemen welcome to
the Tim Dylan show with his Tim Dylan
the keto Kid the greatest athlete in the
United States of America right now I
have the heart of a lion I am in ketosis
I pissed on a strip Ben did as well he
is not in ketosis his body is burning
glucose like a fat [ __ ]
like a fat yeasty [ __ ] burning glucose
there is a crazy woman screaming on the
other side of the property but you know
not our property but she's somewhere
else and we might have to shut her down
we might have to have her on the show we
don't know where it's gonna go but she
is screaming she is using slurs she
would not be hired at SNL I don't know
who she is I don't know what she looks
like if she can use those slurs or not
if you get my drift
is she allowed to say what she's saying
I don't know it's too dark to tell
and we're separated thankfully by a
hedge so I don't know what's going on
but I will let you know if there's any
interruption in the episode that's
probably gonna be the cause I I had a
epiphany today the keto ice creams in
the keto [ __ ] it's not it's not the
move everybody wants to find the version
of what they used to do the synthetic
heroin so to speak y'all just takes a
boxing which you need while you detox I
guess but you know people people just
stay on methadone people so with these
ice creams they don't have sugar in them
are filled with sugar alcohols that [ __ ]
your stomach up I don't even know how to
pronounce one of them is sorbitol the
other one is a fear at all or something
I don't know how to pronounce it
and these these sugar alcohols really
[ __ ] you up you just start [ __ ] I
remember I had sorbet chocolate sorbet
at Red Mango when I was a tour guide on
those double-decker buses in New York
City and it went through me so quickly
in the middle of showing people the 9/11
memorial I had to run off the bus and
just violently [ __ ] in Starbucks I had
to run in a Starbucks he just starts
screaming until they took me seriously I
had to cut like four people in line on
my ID and then there was just a tour bus
full of people hearing they had that
they were they were pausing and probably
starting to Google a lot of the stuff I
had mentioned you know when I when I
went by the 9/11 memorial I was you
couldn't you can't just start going
straight up crazy but you can like you
can like I would deliver it very
sarcastically I'm like you know 19 hide
it came as a total surprise
nobody knew nobody had even an inkling
he's crazy [ __ ] is still [ __ ] goin
man she's still going uh uh you know
what are you gonna do let her do it
she's this is who she this is you know
this is what it is
you know God God love her and whatever
she did was to just explain to people
you just hear bursts of earth talking
now she's either on her phone but I
don't think so no she's just yelling and
she's kind of she said the n-word
multiple times and I
I don't know what's going on now there
was a woman who basically got caught not
too far from here
screaming the n-word in a CVS parking
lot and I wonder if it's the same woman
she was fired from her job within the
hour which is clearly deserved go watch
the video she just goes in hard and it's
not even like there's no defense it is
bad you know and she was fired from her
job within an hour see if we can find
out what that job was and all of her
neighbors had had a restraining order on
her already
prior to her going nuts and screaming
slurs in a CBS CBS I'm so [ __ ]
Hollywood CVS parking lot I wonder what
I looked into this because I found her
on my next door page okay she's in the
neighborhood and and now explained what
next-door is because next door is a
great thing for people to be racist in
their neighborhood and and I was sort of
the Whitney Cummings about it if you go
on next door in her neighborhood which
is a nice neighborhood and people like a
black eye again and she's like he's
delivering FedEx you [ __ ] animal
get the [ __ ] off next door what kind of
rat sweb site is this what is it it's
only for snitching they say hey just I
want to let everybody know I saw a
Mexican with a backpack on the corner of
46th and and you know whatever just
letting everyone and everyone's like
yeah he lives there yes
oh [ __ ] is I mean who's running this but
you got couches off it right yeah I got
free couches so also people in the
middle of a racist diatribe can give
away a dresser yes if you need it you
like by the way I've noticed a few too
many Mexicans recently I do have a
beautiful ottoman that were we no longer
it need so if you want to come and get
it just be careful about the Mexicans
because we don't know they're very
physically unpredictable it could just
jump at you next door I love that it
combines racism with charity racism and
generosity the next store
you know yeah people are Jesus Christ
people are like I've been noticing some
strange going on goings-on in this
neighborhood I don't like it but I do
like to help young families get a start
so I do have a kitchen table if you want
to come and pick it up you will have to
hear me talk about the Jews for a little
bit but that's a small price to pay for
a sturdy kitchen table that served me
well for many years you Rick go on the
next drive you realize we're living it
with it paranoid people are so [ __ ]
paranoid like I remember when I was
growing up literally they were like
everybody's trying to kidnap and rape
you know that they were right about that
we took awhile to realize they were
right about that but not us like they
weren't trying to kidnap and rape us it
was was other kids but it was happening
but there was like the white van then
you're probably too young but it was
like the white van the guy in the white
van if you were from Long Island and you
can hit me up on social media
I had blocked a few people today cuz
there tried to be funny they were not
funny
so you got blocked you run the risk I
don't always block I rarely block but if
I look back at our our history and
you've you've tried five unfunny jokes
in messenger to me your God you're gone
no one has the time you got to get
better
or stop so one guy messages music hey oh
the film gray state it's about
totalitarian government and and I know a
little bit about it I was the guy who
made it he got killed and his family got
killed can you get the Cuba the word out
about the two who dummy you get the word
out to who to my listeners and what are
they gonna do get the word out to who
that got the feds who probably killed
the guy what word do you want Epstein
the word is out the word does
matter the word doesn't matter buddy
what kind of are you people Daft good
can you help get the word the word is
out it doesn't matter it is immaterial
people know Epstein was the biggest news
story in the world and it just fell off
the word is out think anyone gives a
[ __ ] so stop with this [ __ ] will you
message me get the word out can you get
the word up you get it out this [ __ ] is
still yelling I cannot believe we think
she's gonna come in here I'll put it
right on Mike I'll put it right on Mike
and we'll lose it all we'll lose it all
get the word out when you were in Long
Island when you were a kid there was
always a guy it was a pedophile in a
white van driving around trying to
kidnap kids and this was something they
would have like an assembly about it
which means they bring all the parents
into the school and they go there's a
man and a wife and then they send
letters home with you and you give you
will you shut up they give let they'd
send letters shut up or come on the show
they'd send letters home talking about
the guy in a white van and in my parents
didn't give a [ __ ] about me I was like
that's fine you'll be fine but just
paranoia and you go in the next door
thing and it's just paranoid people
think they're being robbed people think
people are conspiring to rob their
shitty house your shitty house you think
people are trying to knock over your
house to get $18 in petty cash that you
keep on the counter next to a couple
Arby's wrappers calm down the paranoia
in this country that everyone's trying
to kill you and every goddamn moment you
know terror is on you know they talk
about the opioid epidemic like people
walking around with syringes full of
heroin injecting them into people and
turning them into zombies
you know they talk about it like they
don't talk about any of the causes any
of the reasons it might be happening you
know areas of bendy industrialized
there's no jobs they they separated from
all that there's a few books that go
into that but for the most part it's all
they're all on the news I hope you're
that but now we got it saw just people
running around these dope fiends these
kids are doing heroin and people are um
we're the next door app man she's still
going she's still going you think is
there a chance she's on like a drug hmm
probably I mean yeah it sounds like
she's thrashing around in the bushes too
does sound like she's thrashing around
in the bushes he's the trying to get in
here no not in here she's up on the hill
but she's up on the hill well that's
nice isn't it she could roll down maybe
at some point she's on the hill folks no
need to worry she's up on the hill you
sign in the next door and uh yeah I'm on
it go what do we got on next door right
now cuz we got a post about this [ __ ]
cuz she's [ __ ] my patients Tom kiddin
we're not rats let her roll around in
that grass and scream I don't give a
[ __ ] what she does
I don't rat on anybody for anything I
don't care mm-hm
I don't rat it's against my Constitution
I don't like that Takashi six nine sit
what's his name Takashi six not got it
yeah I don't like that you wouldn't see
dozy cat ratting or little Zen maybe
little Zen I don't know zan is a complex
man mm-hmm
what is next door what are some of the
posts on next door right now okay so top
post human excrement removal human
excrement removal dear neighbors
somebody was nice enough to leave a big
pile of human excrement in front of my
house today hoping my kids don't
accidentally step in it does anybody
know of a city service I can call to
have it removed hey how do you know it's
human this is a guy who's somebody's
putting [ __ ] in front of his house and
this guy deserves it I can tell already
I can tell
this guy you don't know how to remove
[ __ ] you put it in the bag this is a
someone is putting [ __ ] on his property
for good reason
hopefully my kids don't step in it will
tell him not to step in it
why are you playing a guessing game with
the kids what else do you got do people
answer this idiot
the heute yeah so let's see the top
comment
dear justice this happened to us many
years ago the person nicely did their
thing right up against our house I took
pictures and showed it to the next
council meeting people couldn't believe
it council meeting the City Council
I guess the neighborhood council yeah I
mean King can you imagine just for a
minute
I want everyone listening this to
imagine how meaningless people's lives
are like how meaningless this guy's
taking pictures of [ __ ] and then
bringing it up in the city can I
understand if it happens every day or
even once a week but one time only you
know lucky you are that's all that's
ever happened one time somebody just
shits on your house but think of the
inane meaningless lives that people have
that they need to fill they get so
excited when there's a mound of [ __ ]
that they can photograph they're so
happy I advanced like that when
something goes wrong they get excited
they get real they're like happy they
love to tell a tragic story I've an aunt
that goes she get her face full fills
with life at the dinner table when she
goes hey you know Jessica Jessica you
know her brother her brother jumped off
the bridge you know the bridge and
everybody jumps off yeah he jumped off
paralyzed so maybe you don't do that
don't do that anymore and she's she's
happy as a pig and shin when she's able
to talk about tragedy she loves it she
loves she'll bring up she'll be like you
know kid I knew took a little xanax
drank fell down the stairs dad to kid he
lived three Doors over now he's dead
took the xanax had a couple of beards at
a party fell down the stairs I'm like
why I don't even take xanax and I'm
sober why are we doing this why are we
going over this we're gonna start just
going tragedy by tragedy she used to be
like there were little mini rocks in the
school I grew up so she'd go you know
someone that one kid is gonna eat those
rocks one day and die and she just loved
it she was into it she loves you know
she gets into it okay I get it to an
extent because I love and I talk about
this with a friend the other day I
happen to love and I don't really admit
this often or or talk about this because
people might take it the wrong way and
it's not my fault I happen to really
enjoy funerals I love funerals
I love the wake I love the burial I love
the drive to the funeral everything
about a fuer I love seeing people you
haven't seen in a while but in a space
where you know you don't have to keep up
it's weird to exchange numbers nobody's
serious nobody's gonna follow up with
each other in a week and go hey we saw
each other at the funeral you'd be
insane if you did that you'd be like
what so if you even reconnect at a
funeral it's so brief it's so surface
it's so shallow it's so nice it's so
nice a have you been and I good I like
to cry I like to be sad and think about
my own mortality and feel bad for other
but I like to look at other people that
have lost a loved one and feel bad for
them and sometimes it's nice when it's
an older person who we could all say
what's a life well-lived
but sometimes it's nice when it's
someone younger sometimes it's nice when
it's somebody it was unexpected or
someone and we all have to really
reflect on what it means because the
older people you don't have to reflect
on what it means as much you get it they
lived a good life but sometimes it's got
to be dark and real tragic and they've
got to be young
it's got to be young to really get to
cry on and get to purge
heard you got a question what is life
why are we here am I on the right track
these are very important things LA they
have silent retreats and yoga in the
Northeast we had funerals people would
just die and you would go I loved I
loved the meal have you ever had a
funeral meal will you go out afterwards
and everybody's eating and you're
relaxing it's kind of fun again it's
kind of nice again yes we buried someone
and they're not here but that means more
shrimp cocktail for us we're here we're
alive no disrespect
Paul Ruis a great man would love this
attitude passed away at 44 I feel very
bad man was he [ __ ] funnier than
comedians and I know that doesn't say
much but God it's not [ __ ] funny was
it we guy fieri loved him he was a chef
he opened the great restaurant in New
York or la Cubana the guy was hit he
texted me a photo on Twitter that made
me laugh harder than some anything else
I'm gonna show it to Ben right now dude
and this is and familiarize yourself
with the great call Ruiz if you have it
because I'm telling you right now this
guy everybody loved him Sherrod small
you know Opie and Anthony Vic n Lee all
these comics really love Coll Ruiz and
he was a partier man he was he would
break Bilborough
crack Bober up tell stories about doing
coke in the in the kitchen when he was
coming up as a chef and he had like a
spot in Jersey and then he had and then
he just opened his spot in the
Meatpacking District and he sent me a
message and it's one of its one of the
funniest things that anyone has ever
sent me okay and he goes he goes this is
what follows you when you are a food
celebrity human garbage pelicans and
it's just a picture of these two fat
women
we're birthday hats on and like you know
a filter the gates and birthday hats you
see if ever heard that city goes this is
who follows you and your food celebrity
human garbage pelicans it is one of the
funniest things I I laugh so [ __ ] and
iMessage guy and I said I got to see you
when I'm in New York we get and he goes
come to the restaurant let's eat
I wanted him on the podcast I wanna he
there's a video that Opie just posted on
Twitter when they walk into his
apartment or a hotel I don't know it's
beautiful
it's like in the middle of Manhattan or
whatever and he's just got cash wads of
cash laying on the table and everybody
starts going what the hell's going on in
here Maurice just looks at because you
know I'm a walking felony the guy lived
he was a vandalism I wish he was still
here I wish he live [ __ ] forever that
guy was great but it's like my friend's
father passed away who we love this guy
was great we used to get you know get
hammered all that enough she's still
going we used to get hammered I mean
what has happened we used to drink all
the time and have fun go out to dinner
with this guy and he passed away in his
early 60s and and the funeral was so sad
because he was dead but there was
something about a funeral and there are
people out there that know what I mean
they know what I mean right now and
they're looking at each other going [ __ ]
he's right and it's been a while since
we've been to one and it would be nice
you know a nice autumn day whoo nice
autumn day some nice hymnals uh and I
will raise you up on eagle's wings raise
you up above all things I don't know the
rest but that you know in a nice church
you go out in your black suit maybe yeah
maybe a bum a smoke maybe you don't I
don't know you know that's all what you
have to do and maybe it's in a sit-down
restaurant or maybe after would you do
something at a bar and you're just some
wings in a couple of cocktails my friend
Michael's mother I mean let me tell you
right now what I don't want anyone to
die but the meatballs I had at the after
dinner I would kill her myself
I would stretch they were so good soft
that's what meatballs should be and I
don't listen she fought cancer very long
time the woman had more she was more of
a fighters who tougher and she got more
out of life than I will ever get and any
of my clown friends will ever get out of
life
away because she helped other people and
she had this camaraderie with other
people who are fighting this thing and
she raised money for people and it was
really amazing to look at somebody's
life was cut short but not in in in
[ __ ] substance at all she went
through hell but when you talk about
somebody who's a warrior champion I mean
I what's good about what I do is I spend
time with people who lead meaningless
lives utterly meaningless lives devoid
of honor devoid of anything people that
just float around and you know but the
food at this place and I mean I'm
talking about quesadillas
they had Italian they had wings it was
like a bar restaurant and I was sitting
down with a bunch of people I'd never
met I didn't know them and I felt I was
having one of the best times I've ever
had
so here's I will throw this out I don't
want to I don't want this to seem weird
if you want me to go to a funeral of
someone you know I will go as long as
it's doesn't you know as long as it
doesn't feel weird I like to I like to
hear about somebody's life you know
people say to me when I go to funerals
ago did you know this person well and
I'm like I don't need to know somebody
well to go and take stock of a life I
think it's a beautiful thing and I enjoy
it I don't know there are people out
here that say this is a sociopath
talking or I'm insane every episode
there's probably that reaction but
that's not the case here this is a
beautiful thing when someone is ripped
from us not when it's a young person
unless they're very young if they're
very very young it's fine because you
don't know you know what I mean if
they're very young it's fine again very
very young but if it's if it's in the
middle of their life 22 30s it's real
rough and once 60 above again it's it's
fine so what I'm trying to say and I've
dug a little bit of a hole here probably
with certain people but I
people need to admit and my my
grandmother had a great funeral she was
like 89 and the priest went up and he
goes Dorothy and Ray copped the great
Ray accomplished sitting there most
people did that the the the mortician
thought the funeral was for him they
said well he looks fine
well not fine it looks better than most
of the corpses he's smoking for instance
but my my grandmother the priest went up
and he did this Hellfire and brimstone
speech goes Dorothy has been preparing
for this moment for decades decades
shifting in our seats because we were
like [ __ ] whoa basically he was laying
it on the line priests and funerals
that's their time that's it I my
grandfather's funeral beautiful bagpipes
bagpipes an Irish funeral everybody
bombed these are beautiful thing
much better than weddings weddings suck
uh what's the other thing when the kids
bought baptisms and christenings [ __ ]
off I love a good funeral because you
you really appreciate life you
appreciate being a lot when you drive
out of out of a wake and you're sitting
there and you're you drive out of a
burial that maybe it was Holy Rood
cemetery in Hicksville and you're
sitting there at the stoplight and a
song comes on and it's a decent song and
you know the sun's out and you drive in
maybe stop in a 7-eleven you get a
Snapple and you just say to yourself I'm
[ __ ] here I I would go to one a month
if I could so that I just want to throw
that out to people if you want me at
your funeral and I'd do the whole thing
but I do wake burial and then whatever
dinner is lunch or dinner that we're
doing I'd do the whole I do the whole
thing I do the wake and I come back the
next day for the burial and if you tell
me that the burial is only from the
family I come because I want to be that
I want to see it go into the ground
that's when it's poetic and meaningful
to me and listen it is what it is you
know I'm not I don't like death I like
funerals
they're beautiful things Long Island
people have a couple of cocktails here
eConnect
it's really and there's a lot of lucky
people right now because so many people
are dropping dead on Long Island from
heroin addiction and there are so many
lucky people that get to go to these
events all the time and really kind of
reconnect you know I'll see you at the
funeral
that's what they say well what else on
the next door app do we have here
because then I want to get into pyramid
schemes for a minute next post title
says cop cars --all what cop cars but
with an L at the end it's just cars with
an L at the end they what the [ __ ] is
that they can't type this this woman
sherry she can't type sherry she says
anybody know what's going on on los la s
she didn't and someone comedy said
that's going on is it this woman right
now laying in the [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
in the get up in the grass rolling
around is this so that woman's clearly
drunk or something right yeah she died
mid posed what is that does anyone know
what's going on on loss and what what is
I don't even know what that is it's
nothing it's nothing it's what else what
else is this this app fascinates me by
the way this what is it a Salyut is it
an app you can get it on your phone -
yeah you have to sign up and register
your address through it so it's a whole
like two week long semester now no you
have to have your name and address you
name an address and you get to be as
racist as you want as long as you own it
with your name and address great
personal injury attorney I am asking for
a friend if anyone can recommend a
bulldog personal injury attorney in the
LA area okay that seems an odd thing to
put I love by the way that gets me that
brings on like all those people the
crowdsource everything they do in their
life like you'll see them they're like I
want to read more does anyone have any
suggestions of books and they asked
their social media network they asked
their Facebook friends and could there
be any less like could you want
suggestions less
from a group of people than your
Facebook people are still actively using
Facebook hi I want to go to Disney World
we're leaving in 9 months but we thought
we'd start planning now does anyone have
any hotel recommendation and people love
it they go right and they just start
writing paragraph mmm
paragraph paragraph well we stayed at
the Grand Floridian and we liked its
little pricey if it's near to the part
and I'm like [ __ ] go on YouTube they
review every Hotel every single hotel in
Disney World how far it is away from the
park mmm what the foods like what they
review everyone people do that now you
don't need to crowdsource you don't have
a trusted friend that reads you got to
go on Facebook and go is there any books
I want to read a book I'm in my mid 30s
and it's occurred to me recently that
I'm an idiot can any of you recommend a
book yeah Harry Potter you dumb [ __ ]
stop crowd so people crowdsource their
honeymoon hi we're we don't know where
to go
can anyone you've you've never wanted to
go anywhere someone else needs to tell
you where to go on your honeymoon I
always do in the way to fight fire with
fire
any time somebody asks for a
recommendation for a realtor or anything
they go hi I'm moving and I want to know
you you find the wealthiest area in
wherever they're going
and you recommend the realtor who sells
houses there to make them feel like [ __ ]
like when when I have friends and these
are comedians they have no money they're
moving to LA and they're like hey I'm
just anybody no room open and even no
room for like 700 mi I comment Joyce ray
who's a realtor that sells estates in
Beverly Hills and I and it says luxury
estates and then like sometimes you'll
go oh I can't afford that and I'm like
well that's not my fault
but always do that always try to make
people feel like [ __ ] who are being
stupid so if somebody goes hey I want a
realtor maybe
just a little bit out of their league
but find a realtor look at the listings
and and really and make them say like
hey it's a little out of my league and
then just write back oh sorry sorry
always find something a little bit out
of their league I do it where people
know it's a joke it's it's really
because I don't have time to really do
it appropriately but you can do it real
good where you just recommend something
recommend a restaurant that's a little
out of their league and and be like hey
I don't know if you're into this type of
thing but here you go you know it's fun
to do it's fun to let people know
they're trash in little fun ways just
let them know I always love when people
will crowdsource a restaurant and I'm
like just try it out or go to some go to
someone you trust or find an institution
you trust whether it's a paper that may
reviewed the restaurant or if you're in
the Yelp and that [ __ ] you can do
that I just say a ticket to put people
make it out to be this big deal this big
deal and they're like well I don't know
should we go to Peter Lugar's or should
we go to quality meets I don't know and
then people get in a fight in the
comments it's like hey go to both go to
neither who gives a [ __ ] it's a two
hundred dollar dinner if it's if it's
the one time you're gonna do it in your
life don't do it spend the money on
medicine or water I know people are
hurting but you need not have a 300
comment fight about who's got a better
steak try it or don't do it it's amazing
to me
I love next door app I want to get I'm
gonna sign up and just start going wild
I'm gonna start making things up hi
there was a bunch of guys walking around
with tiki torches has anyone seen that
there's a lot of Russians in the area
there's been a lot of Russians I'm
thinking maybe it's possible
this has something to do with Trump I
don't know but well what else we got on
title of this one is No why can you
never talk while you always have to
clear throat before you talk on the
podcast yo he's got ya wrong with you
when you talk on this show this is the
most people who've ever heard your voice
probably when whoever will a title of
this post is no see um does anybody know
what to do to get rid of noseeums these
bugs are driving us crazy that well
that's the most reasonable thing we've
heard so far what is that well I would
number one you would probably call an
exterminator but I guess they want to do
it on the cheap and you know so they're
really tiny bugs so now can you just
troll on here and can you just what do
you want me to post I'll post something
right now say noseeums or with you
forever you you must leave the home go
noseeums are never not with you just go
the no seeum say the noseeums are
attracted to pedophiles is there
something going on that we should know
about the noseeums are attracted to the
blood of pedophiles that's maybe why
they're biting you man
troll folks have a little fun out there
are you sad do you need help do you want
to speak to a counselor who may or may
not be licensed better help take a
chance better help they had a massive
scandal on YouTube people were very
angry but I'm sure it's fine now better
help better help are you upset with the
way things are going and you can't
afford a real doctor and you want to
talk to you a stranger call better
hell you know the way I feel about
better help folks it's a service where
you will call a person and they have to
speak to you tell them your problems
masturbate on the phone of their voice
I've suggested that it does not matter
to me what you do if you get off on
touching yourself while a stranger talks
to you this is the perfect time to kind
of do that because I don't I'm sure the
counselors are better than not listen
better help is better than nothing it's
better than nothing help that's the
point and that's where we're at a lot of
people are in a desperate situation
where they go you know what I need
something that's better than nothing
have you ever pulled into a rest stop
and you went well it's it's better than
starving that's what this is it's better
than nothing it's better than the
[ __ ] wall or staring at a cat at all
cats
I would imagine because some of them
should have wisdom in their face but
it's not really all of them but well I'm
saying better help you know what I steer
you wrong what I tell you a bunch of
[ __ ] cuz I'm getting paid to say it what
I I can't believe I would 10% off your
first month by going to better help calm
Jim Dylan this is our last ad with them
right pen oh [ __ ] you got one more after
this what is the helicopter doing all
the time what are they doing with the
copter 10% off first month better help
calm slash Tim Dylan simply fill out a
questionnaire me and Ray did it it's
very easy it takes 30 to 40 minutes to
help them assess your needs to get back
to the professional counselor if you're
gay you can go to pride counseling calm
that's the first question like who are
you what's your sexuality I'm like is
this a dating site I'm upset maybe I
don't know what my sexuality is maybe I
saw something in a locker room that's
made me confused
I remember I saw a penis I was where was
I in seventh grade eighth grade I don't
know and I was on swim team it was
before that and there was a kid who I
like an adult penis before he should
have and it was just insane like every
now and then you see a penis and you
know that that person's gonna have a
better life than you no matter what they
do like they'll just have a better life
most likely I don't really know but I
remember look at that penis and
understanding like well that guy's gonna
do better than me you know
um better help right that's what we're
talking about listen what do you want to
[ __ ] you want to do something stupid
go better help they'll [ __ ] get you
going
who cares what a doctor's what our
licenses what's Medical School so fake
does it matter
you don't need vaccines you don't want
to lower your immunity better help it's
better than nothing you get on the phone
you say hello I'm upset and they'll
they'll talk you down they'll talk you
off the ledge I think you fill out a
questionnaire it's quick and easy lets
you connect with the professional
accounts or the safe and private online
environment anything you share is
confidential except of course the NSA
who will take everything that you say
and put it in a in a you know some type
of cloud or whatever there and then
eventually when the time comes give it
to the feds
it'll be prevented presented as evidence
at your tribunal but I'm sure better
help I'm sure they I'm sure they're not
working with the NSA the NSA doesn't
want to hear a bunch of losers drone on
France better help is it a scam who
knows
I wouldn't advertise a product on this
show that wasn't a scam I want you to
know that I select scams I've given
scams all the time
and I just want to let you know because
I care about you
most of not kidding the CBD is legit all
that shit's legit it's real CBD we've
what are we [ __ ] what do you think my
bookie is good better help is the one
this is the one thing right morally go
you know what do I really do here I mean
I signed the thing I didn't really sign
anything I haven't you know an
outstanding amount of ads to do I have
this one ad and then the next ad and
they're not really doing any more ads
for them but I like I listen it's not
the worst thing is what I'm saying I'm
not trying to kill you
I'm not selling it boys I'm not selling
you Opie they're people that sell you
heroin in the street they're people that
sell you children heroin I'm not doing
that you get it people that sell your
kids oxycontin and you find them the
next day with blue lips I'm selling you
counseling I get mad at me I'm just
telling you could call someone to talk
to him I'm not selling you some shitty
mortgage I may have in the past I saw
myself as shitty mortgage we all took
him he didn't take one out you were a
[ __ ] but don't don't get mad at me is my
point
better help promo code Tim you get a
little money off stop [ __ ] around I'm
acting like I'm trying to kill you all
I'm doing is trying to help you
trying to help you better you know I
don't know what goes on I don't have
problems I do have problems but they
become you know comedy I guess better
help alright my friend my friend sister
went on Facebook or maybe was Instagram
whatever social media and she goes hey I
just want to let everybody know
beachbody.com is not a pyramid scheme
okay there's a lot of misinformation out
there it's not a pimp now what Beachbody
is for those of you who don't know is
it's like this pyramid scheme clearly a
multi-level marketing scheme like Amway
or like anything else which is based on
you converting your dumb friends and
selling them [ __ ] because they're fat
and you go oh a group of friends we're
all gonna motivate each other better
than celebrities and trainers will um
know your group of friends is why you're
fat you don't change with the group of
friends you get rid of them you get rid
of the fatties no G a group of friends
is the reason you're [ __ ] you're gonna
try to you're gonna try to change six
people's lives at once who the [ __ ] does
that so that that's the whole thing
about by Beachbody and then you become
like a coach or a Beachbody Coach and
you put up all these motivational things
like it's 5 a.m. and I want to stay in
bed but I'm not cuz I'm a Beachbody
Coach now if you buy the the meals and
the shakes you too can be a Beachbody
Diamond member and and you just climb up
this but I love you so Beachbody by the
way of course had to like address the
idea that they were this multi-level
marketing thing okay and to me it was
one of the funniest things ever because
basically they didn't tell you that they
like they have no argument that they're
not so get that up by the way bang get
the Beachbody
they literally have no argument that
they are not and I like when I was
performing at the Spokane comedy club in
Washington I saw a bunch of people in
suits and you know that area is weird
it's gray its dreary it's like really
kind of Twin Peaks II and there's all
these weird people and the teenagers
young people old people every race and
they're all walking in suits to an arena
and I'm like what is it is it Christian
thing what is it and it was like this
amway spinoff this worldwide Dream
builders online marketing cult and would
they all recruit people it's like Mary
Kay Cosmetics you know and if you sell a
lot you get the pink Cadillac and you
got to just convert your friends and
have these parties and stuff and I'm all
for ripping off and [ __ ] over your
friends do it smart though
do you have it up here I have this long
article but it's a too long didn't read
version right here about Beachbody
nobody's the B is this the Beachbody
site no let me I get that word and it's
so bad at his job it's amazing it's
amazing
Beachbody they actually on their website
they're basically like listen we're not
a pyramid scheme wikipedia defines a
pyramid scheme is this does that sound
like what we're doing and then the
difference between what they do and what
an actual pyramid scheme is is literally
nothing and as you read it it's got a
cycle Arius they're like hey but date no
one's going to that page because they
know the people that are on it have been
bit they're feral they've been bitter
Atty
so once you've been bit no one can tell
you that you haven't uh you know that
you you need to reassess it's on their
website man it's like a frequently asked
question it's like is beachbody.com
a pyramid scheme and and they're there
rationale is is great here we go I found
it first then this is one of my favorite
things ever when you read this you're
still looking for it is it in the about
us in the mission it's the first thing
that comes up on Google thank God we
don't bring things up on the shelf you
know because he's just completely I mean
that's your one job is to just bring up
the [ __ ] article how have I found it
how did I get it it's the first thing on
Google what did you Google I went to the
Beachbody website cuz he said it was the
first thing on the website well why
wouldn't you just put it into google the
search engine and see what came out
anyway Beachbody discusses pyramid
schemes in multi-level marketing right
this is great you may be asking is
direct selling the same as multi-level
marketing is it a pyramid scheme a Ponzi
scheme is it a scam how do people make
money and what's the opportunity for me
lots of great questions and we'll take
one by one simply put according to
Wikipedia Direct Selling is the
marketing and selling of products
directly to consumers away from a fixed
retail location so it's the guy that
shows up opens his trunk and sells you
shed in other words that's not what it
says on Wikipedia I'm adding that in
this is what they say they go so what
about pyramid schemes a pyramid scheme
or Ponzi scheme is something completely
different and far more harmful like a
scam that's far more harmful it's like a
scam his Beachbody a pyramid scheme now
Team Beachbody Coaches make money from
actual sales of genuine fitness and
nutrition products and hard work not
from recruiting fees or business fees
coaches are never paid to recruit people
and do not earn money from recruiting
you they earn money when they sell
people to [ __ ] our mission is to help
people live healthier more fulfilling
lives how did people become coaches do
they make money by selling Shakeology
our coaches start as customers right ala
pyramid scheme Beachbody
once they start to get results people
tend to notice and ask what they are
doing no one does that by the way people
oh you look great you lost weight some
people go what do you do it you go I got
nobody wants to hear at that point
people only want to hear like a one-word
answer Lokar slow carb keto paleo walk
around the block
I cut out booze nobody wants to hear
this like it asked me you look a little
thinner what do you been doing you look
a little thinner what have you been
doing take a seat
I've been waiting for you to ask me this
I'd become a member of a very fulfilling
new group that holds each other
accountable have you heard of Shakeology
I haven't why are you looking at me like
that sit down and get ready for the
secret I'm about to tell you the secret
about Shakeology some companies have
used direct sales model will you where
are you going I just want to talk about
Shakeology do you have your credit card
on you we can get you started right now
they enjoy helping others achieve the
results they've achieved using Beachbody
products and want to share with others
so they sign up to be coaches you could
sign up to be a coach for $40 dude we're
doing this $40 I could sign up to be a
coach Plus 16 16 a month 1595 recurring
monthly fee 16 a month to be ok
this covers ongoing access to their
website training reporting personal
development content plus all the backend
operation of warehousing and shipping
products so then you gotta sell to
people ok don't take our word for it
here's Team Beachbody Coach Joan
Crocker's story she's been suffering
from depression and was gaining weight
her husband introduced her to Beachbody
she bought insanity and worked out hard
to the complete 60 day program she said
I found my confidence in happy again and
happiness again I felt better physically
mentally and emotionally and then I
decided I wanted to rob others
here's team Jen Richardson Story
Beachbody she was two months postpartum
with her second son and searching for
teaching jobs or she could put her
master's degree to use but because the
country is a bag of [ __ ] she decided to
sell people fitness shakes because life
is a hell like that if this was honest
that's what it would really she tried to
use her master's degree but because she
couldn't find any work she decided it
was much more fulfilling to start
Hawking fitness shakes to her friends
that was a much better way to go about
earning money sure she had her passion
was for education she wanted to teach
kids how to read but hey you know it's a
good close second teaching your fat
friend how to hawk shakes Shakeology let
me tell you about shake Allah
I would plunge a knife in it my own
throat before I would sit down and have
to look at someone in the face and say
the words Shakeology if you say the word
Shakeology with a straight face you need
to be in a cell you need to have the
door shut I love people that don't have
any problem ripping off their friend
like getting their friends in a cult
it's so hilarious to me when people are
just so like hey man
good to see you that's how I got my
[ __ ] house when I bought that house
with a subprime mortgage I got
foreclosed one of my best friends was
like it's a great opportunity and me cuz
I was coked to the gills when your third
girl he's like it's a big yard a
developer is gonna come in they'll
subdivide the plot you'll be making
crazy money
sounds good just doing coke I said I
love you and George W Bush I'm gonna be
a homeowner I love you boy I love Dick
Cheney we need to honor our commitments
to the people of Iraq No Child Left
Behind is a good program thinking
things people repeat like the platitudes
people repeat meaningless they don't
know anything
barely know what No Child Left Behind is
that people fight about it they argue
about it but have no idea what it is
picture me coked to the gills in a bar
looking at somebody No Child Left Behind
creates accountability
it creates accountability and incentives
he's [ __ ] teachers are paid too much
money which I still feel but I don't the
program I don't know you know that but I
did achieve you know the complaining of
the teachers has got to stop at a
certain point you know um
yes--she college i love it it's 6:00
a.m. I was gonna sleep in but that's not
what I'm about I just made a quick shake
and I'm ready to work out burn some cows
hey do you want to look and feel good -
we'll get your credit card out cuz imma
bet you want to come on in you're gonna
be a coach you start as a fat [ __ ] but
you end up a coach don't you want to be
a coat well I don't have any skills shut
up
you're gonna be a coach I don't really
know anything about nutrition and
fitness it doesn't matter
the people at Shakeology have provided
us with all the information we'll need
all you have to find is five other fat
fox that a desperate that have
postpartum depression I love who this is
being marketed to
they're like genies story was great she
was laying on the floor of her trailer
who's this product for people that have
given up all hope Cheney was sitting in
her car with the engine on in her garage
she was three ghasts away from meeting
Jesus and then Cheney went inside and
she went and she saw that her good
friend at work had lost three pounds by
drinking shakes all day so Jeannie said
God her friend had posted on Facebook
that there was a unique money-making
opportunity in the fitness world Jeannie
had always wanted a beach body she never
had
she had uh you know scores she had a
stretch marks it looked like spiders
crawling up her stomach but she wanted
that beach body so she saw one of her
friends on Facebook oh hey are you
laying on the floor of your apartment
thinking of reasons not to kill yourself
maybe you should become a Beachbody
Coach you can look good and feel good I
love who this is marketed to let's keep
going on the by the way I wonder if any
of them were like this person was doing
good and they decided to get involved or
is everybody as well gun in their mouth
before they decide which of course you
have to to lower yourself to this to
lower yourself to Hawking fitness shakes
to your friends it you have to be ready
to kill yourself let's see if there's
Hilary Kelley remembers her early days
as a Team Beachbody Coach and how she
built her business you artwork I'm not a
nutrition expert but I started with the
simple approach of sharing my story both
in person and on Facebook here's how
that should have ended I'm not a
nutrition expert so I didn't get
involved end of post I'm not a nutrition
expert so I shut my mouth and went on my
merry way
but no she decided she knows I'm not a
nutrition expert but I started with a
simple approach of sharing my story both
in person and on Facebook
I think people respond to that I had no
agenda except to help people get fit if
you break it down that's what this
business is all about yeah these people
talk in [ __ ] like pamphlets you know
right I had no agenda
who said she did [ __ ] you seem a little
guilty doth protest too much
they're like it's not a pyramid scheme I
had no agenda I'm not [ __ ] yeah I
didn't do anything I didn't go in your
purse when you were in the bathroom what
are you saying what do you mean there
was $20 on the wallet when I walked
there you better talk to Shakeology I
love all of the [ __ ] examples of
people that they use she was suffering
from depression and was gaining weight
her husband introduced to the Beachbody
her husband was like listen you fat sad
[ __ ] you better clean it up and you
better start bringing in some money into
this house what a nice guy huh he
introduced her to Beachbody she's
depressed
he didn't introduce her to a doctor he
didn't introduce you to a therapist he
introduced you to a multi-level
marketing scam honey you seemed
depressed you don't get out of bed all
day why don't you start Hawking Fitness
plans why don't you get yours monthly
sales numbers up that's why you feel
like [ __ ] because you're laying in bed
every day and not selling shakes to your
friends I love it so much I love it so
much man I love how everybody using this
it's completely our Team Beachbody Coach
network has over 400 thousand strong god
help us and our online communities
million strong meaning no one is ever
alone no matter the goals are how far
anyone thinks they have to go great I
love it
other direct sales companies you may
know Avon Mary Kay Tupperware and Stella
and Dot yet Tupperware parties Avon I
mean I love it I love the stories of the
people two months postpartum with her
second son searching for jobs I think
what coaching really did for my future
goals is give me the belief that
anything I put my mind to I can
accomplish there were several years of
self-doubt where I lock confidence in
myself and coach and turned that around
for me I watched people from all walks
of life create incredible success for
themselves with Beachbody coaching
simply because they believed they could
so what are the coaches do they're
energetic they're enthusiastic the they
are products of the product what a line
they are products of the product I got
to start doing this man up now by the
way I'm gonna tell the audience stairs
if Beachbody contacts me and pays me
money I will sell Shakeology and I will
delete this episode I tell you that all
the time and fold
closure I give a [ __ ] about you pigs I
will I will shove shakes down your
throat so [ __ ] fast you fat slobs I
will put a shake in my ass
if Beachbody tells me to if they want to
spend some [ __ ] money that's what I
do I really cool these companies to try
to get them I'll become a fitness coach
what I gotta make some motivational
Facebook post God do that can easily do
that I used to be fat I used to eat
pizza not even good pizza like Papa
John's Domino's cuz I like to I felt in
my mouth warm and gooey like I was
eating my own insides anyway then I went
online and so a friend of mine was
marginally less fat and I asked her I
said hey fatty
are you less fat she said yes I said
what are you doing she goes well I'm
part of an online community that
provides me the support and the
nutrition products I need and I said
well get me in on the ground floor and
let's go and spread the word of
Shakeology you meet thin people it's
never because they drank shakes it's
never like a fad some of its you could
do keto or a paleo or whatever you know
I'm gonna do keto for as long as I can
but you know you don't do it forever
it's in pot you can't do it forever it
doesn't work forever eventually you
gotta you gotta you gotta you got a
tongue [ __ ] a piece of sourdough I don't
even like sourdough and now it looks
good a little bit I don't even like it
so yeasty bread it's a dumb bread people
in California like it's the only good
thing about it you toast the [ __ ] out of
it you slather it with avocado and
smoked salmon you little avocado toast
Monday calm folks folks folks who's a
businessman I want who is who's a
is this man or a businesswoman are you
or are you not a [ __ ] killer are you
killing it are you crushing it are you
grinding are you hustling are you
winning or are illusion where are you
and what are you doing do you wake up
every day and say today's Monday I'm
gonna I'm gonna go get it I'm gonna
chase it down in the woods and get it
with my bare hands take a bite out of it
draw blood drag it back to a basement
and chained it to something and try to
brainwash it and make it love me that
way you feel that's where I feel about
Monday why Tim why are you so confident
about Monday do you not dread it
do you not do I not dread it like the
rest of you fat nothing's I don't tread
it I wake up and I [ __ ] love Monday I
hate Saturday because Saturday's loser
day everybody spending time with their
kids buying flowerpots at Home Depot or
watching sports
I like Monday when everybody's got to go
to [ __ ] work and earn it and I have
Monday com Monday dot-com is a software
tool that's engineered to help me and
many others maximize our efficiency
whether you are two people that have a
doomed business or thousands of people
collaborating across the globe think the
Epstein Network whatever it is you get
in there with Monday comm there's no
excuse to miss an email there's no
excuse to miss a meeting there's no
excuse that you didn't get the document
where is the invoice none of that
there's no [ __ ] Doreen in their
conference room throwing you under the
bus
there's no [ __ ] somebody stole your
lunch and you're you're all oh you're
all about that and you're not thinking
of
about sales pitch that you have
everything is streamlined it is a great
service and it allows you to be
efficient to worry about developing the
skills that you need to develop being a
liar cheating stealing let Monday calm
provide you the infrastructure to do
that effectively legally Monday that
calm will organize all the other parts
of your business so you could focus on
the most important part hitting people
over the head with a soft touch that's
what matters
going out there and getting it okay let
Monday calm make sure that everybody in
your company and organization is on the
same page while you devote all of your
time to exploiting the relationship you
have with your friends and family
they're all expendable you got to use
them use them or lose them but the last
thing you need is to worry about if the
back-office is running the way it should
be but Monday comm will let you focus on
the important things like putting
together a business plan that allows you
go out into your community and decimate
it and then move on stick and move
hustlers
I'm kidding folks I'm a comedian and
this is what I do I make people laugh
this is my job but many people know me
know that for many years I was
overweight and a drug addict and I was
not organized and now I am an athlete
and I am organized and I am sober for
eight years and Monday comm did that for
me Monday comm is the reason that I am
sober because I was drinking because I
was stressed out at work I would miss an
email I was stressed out and Monday comm
allowed me to maximize my efficiency to
be a more efficient man so after work
instead of get it going and drinking a
bottle of gin and doing cocaine I would
go home and do push-ups and to read the
Bible so I can't overstate the impact
that this particular things had on me
you might be different but I'm what I'm
telling you right now is that if you
have a small business and you don't want
to worry about the BS the horse shite
let your business fail because you don't
have the guts or the drive or the
tenacity or the talent many of you don't
or the ability or the social circle you
know or the raw native intelligence or
the wherewithal you know you don't have
to succeed many of you have empty lives
the wives no kids you know what do you
need a couple more dollars for what more
vapes who cares but for those select few
of you who I call killers crushers
hustlers winners devotees of the
greatest motivational sales tech guru
that has ever lived a Gary Vaynerchuk
Gary Vee Gary Vee help me I can't
explain Gary Vee changed my life a lot
of people think I make fun of Gary Vee
here or make fun of them not really make
fun of guy because he's made millions of
dollars by selling stuff to retards but
what I what I'm now I know that Monday
that confident corporate didn't like
this but the reality is people will use
your service shut up
promo code Tim what is a promo code
slash tip Monday that com slashed him go
get the service folks don't [ __ ] with me
here
the point is Gary Vaynerchuk change my
life I was living in the middle
of a busy highway the 405 in the middle
of it I was just at a tent that was on
the side of the highway and I'd have to
like dash across the highway every time
I want to get someone and I saw bed
accident one night and a woman died in
front of me and her phone was still in
her hand and I grabbed her phone out of
her hand and I saw a quote from Gary Vee
and Gary Vee and then I [ __ ] her and
got kidding I don't [ __ ] women I [ __ ]
her boyfriend who was alive
we had sex on her corpse easy to guess
digital right so if they call me and
they're like don't say this I mean I am
I have to be like guys you know I
thought were the free-speech people what
happened I'm kidding no one had sex with
anybody but I did this is true and real
and I did see her phone and it said
quote from Gary Vee and and the quote
was it said kindness is delicious and I
like that quote because I hadn't eaten
in a while and I realized that I didn't
need food I could just eat kindness I
could pay for things with gratitude and
I realize how important it was to win as
opposed to lose because that was his
other quote stop winning and start
losing and once I read that I was I'd
gangrene all over my leg i cured that
and I was able to just now I have a
mansion that I pay for with gratitude
and to anyone that you think needs help
like a lot of people's country like oh I
want my health care no no no here's what
you need you need to start winning
that's all
start winning I would love by the way
just as an aside if you put Gary van in
your truck like you know these town
halls that they have with Bernie Sanders
where people like ya the debt collectors
came into my son's hospital room you
know and we loved if like Gary
Vaynerchuk was just alright well listen
are you hustling woman in tears she's
like what he's like listen let's be
honest all I heard was excuses from you
you talked about your son you talked
about cancer you know what I didn't hear
I didn't hear any plans for growth
that's what I didn't hear and then if it
was a moral country the people of that
town hall would murder him and they
would use his head they put it on a pike
and use it as a battering ram to go into
the White House and then also burn that
down and start again Monday dot-com
[Music]
slash dim Monday calm slash him okay
all I am saying is used gary
vaynerchuk's head as a battering ram to
get into the White House burn it down
and start again and let's maybe do it
the next time a country that is not run
by satanic pedophiles Monday comm slash
Tim because organization is the first
part of making that happen
goodbye you want it you you know uh
Brendan Schaub and Theo von had a cheese
off on their podcast which makes
millions
ah because of that level of content they
had a cheese off where each of them
recited a cheese shout that like three
cheeses in and then started repeating
you know and so do you do you it's true
he said sharp cheddar twice who's out
theo is pretty good do you do you want
to have a bread off right now yeah one
bread can you do it yeah I think I can
do that no it's interesting I don't know
how strong I am so good on cheese I
don't know how good I am on bread no I
can only name like five shut up do you
believe in yourself yes okay I do what
do you think Jan Richardson a beachbody
would say
she'd say believe okay read off who has
the advantage the person who star to the
other person uh does it matter I don't
think it matters okay would you like to
start a should I start I'll start rye
rye bread is your first yes I'm gonna
try to say basic [ __ ] ones that you
know or should I just say really wild
ones I'm gonna say basic [ __ ] ones to
try to knock you out fast
wheat pumpernickel ooh pretty good my
grandfather like that that was the one
with scare away seeds right and if
you're not enjoying this out there jobs
making there's five Ferraris and that's
what they do so shut the [ __ ] up
um brioche daddy white okay
sourdough then were for in whole grain
I'm gonna allow it because I think it is
I'll allow it
okay holla the Jewish bread it makes the
thick french toast Ezekiel bread I will
yes okay
French bread bread sticks I'll allow it
I'll allow it I'm not thrilled with it
but I'll allow it
ciabatta
do you have breads up no I don't you
could be making up breads I don't even
know I'm not making up ciabatta they had
it at Wendy's
not making up the last one I have is
this one's not fair
garlic knots first of all what the [ __ ]
is wrong with you there's more breads
out there um I will accept garlic knots
okay I'll look now you're just saying
things that are made of bread but I'll
accept it okay um I was gonna say like
olive from Biasi which was a great bread
okay
avid at Marea in New York City my
audience has been no okay
by the way if I sold out an arena and
Steven paddock shot it up he'd get a
Congressional Medal of Freedom and that
she's judging by the comments that you
people leave okay
Steven paddock would be running against
Trump right now if you shot my audience
in the mouth kidding we love each and
every one what was your last bread my
last one was garlic knots but my one
this time now I'm gonna say I'm you say
Allah from yah see I don't know if I'm
pronouncing that right okay um I like
the the raisin bread that I get at the
store has raisins in it you could say
cinnamon raisin Brown yeah okay I'm
going to say no it's interesting I was
gonna say a roll like onion roll but is
that a bread I don't know if that's a
Brad show to keep it fair but a ciabatta
yeah I'm going to say I'm going to go
with a marbled rye [ __ ] [ __ ]
cuz it's a distinctly different bread is
that the one from the Seinfeld episode
the I think should've thought of that
one
I'm about to lose right here I mean oh
there's video you're really not thinking
think of countries a lot of countries
have breads
you're not thinking damn it
can I start naming the breads at Subway
no no I mean I guess I mean it just
doesn't seem sup right a subway way
smells like they're baking a sneaker in
there why does the bread baking process
smell like it's like a sneaker that's
been left out in the rain
what are they baking subway never smells
good no he'd never even smells that was
one of the things we see you know when
we did gets cold and it's on its own
mm-hmm we used to sell the subway were
the thing we used to make fun of using
subway eat fresh with flies because
there was always flies I'm like the the
white tomatoes I'm gonna give you one
say Italian bread dummy is that one I
almost thought of that but is that real
yes I'm talking Italian bread okay
you said Italian bread now bet is lost
already because I've now given you down
so Benny's failed but you've said
Italian bread I'm going to say um I'm
going to say um and this is not fair
either
cuz now I'm starting to blanket I don't
know why I'm [ __ ] blanking there are
other breads there's other [ __ ]
breads out there why am i oh I got one
I'd like shut up shut up you'll be back
to the game when I when I when I when I
when I tell you um so has a bread I'm
going to say uh semolina bread I'm gonna
Google that to make sure that I'm not
full of [ __ ] but I'm I'm pretty sure I'm
not yeah semolina bread semolina bread
semolina bread okay potato bread
potato bread hold on
decides I know this is riveting content
you know shut up are you thinking of
Brad's in your [ __ ] car or wherever
you listen to this [ __ ] you should be
this is this has gotten high should know
a guy shouldn't have given been a
lifeline I got him back in because now
he's pulling things out I could easily
say like cranberry like the cranberry
bread that the haba pet peasant bread
I'm gonna say peasant bread which is a
legitimate bread
it's a genre of bread I'm gonna go
religious unleavened bread unleavened
bread which is matzah I don't know did
you say matzo already
I didn't say mots okay Quito cloud bread
the key though kid all right we'll stop
this at my point is that why is she a
CEO and child making trillions of
dollars doing this cheese they did a
cheese off we just did a bread off
cheese is so much better
hmm there are so many more cheat you
want to just go cheese real quick rapid
fire mozzarella American cheddar Swiss
goat [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] uh Buffalo the
Buffalo is not a cheese blue Gruyere
gorgonzola good Roquefort smoked cheddar
there's ninety chatters Munster cheese
um Stilton that was nice yeah camembert
all right we'll stop here's the point
folks to realize this show is not big
enough because I don't have contempt for
you as an audience enough and I've tried
to entertain you what I believe I should
start doing is nothing and have contempt
for you as an audience and sit here and
instead of giving you unique and funny
insights on the world just start to do
garbage just start to do boring like
let's pass the time [ __ ] like that you
would talk
- you know like you know your buddies -
sleepover when you were in like 11th
grade you got a gay Ben if you could
live I do I
I do love for you and Brandon and I do I
would like to go on King and sting do
they have guests I don't think so
well we're gonna change that because you
know what I've had enough of the nose
I've had enough of the doors slamming in
my [ __ ] face I'm a Kido kid and I'll
get on that [ __ ] show a couple of
pods I need to do what happened with the
your mom's house here's what happened
they had me under ooo again I was in
Cincinnati I'm like my flight is not
gonna get back in time he's gonna chance
your traffic's a [ __ ] nightmare I'm
like I can't do drew so they're like uh
we'll get you on again I think that
might be it they've had like 97 people
on your mom's house since I've come out
of here that's okay that's okay
we're independent we don't need it we
work for Shakeology are you depressed
sad fat well have we got news for you
wait are you doing good no no this is
not for you do you want to live and do
you enjoy life well then our product is
not for you our product is for people
with postpartum depression we're
thinking of sticking their head in an
oven that's who our product is for
that's probably who this podcast is for
- maybe not there are some people that
enjoy this that are yeah I see that I
meet them at shows and they're like you
know young professionals and they're
good-looking and then there are you know
there are the others the ones who dwell
in darkness you know um what did I want
to say before you get out of here I
don't know if I'm doing that
double-decker tour bus around Manhattan
show in November I don't know I don't
know I'm still deciding I may not do it
I probably I'm not doing it as part of
the New York Comedy Festival because I'm
on tour
Christ sure Burt so I am NOT doing that
and I don't know if I'm gonna do it
later in the month it's very possible
that I do it later in the month it's
possible that I don't I still have to
make that decision it's a lot to do it's
a lot to get out there not to get out
there not to fly out there but the bus
rental you know this lot the whole thing
the weather this that insurance the
money that is I I do like it I almost
kind of want to do it one more time to
just to just wrap it up and say goodbye
I'm a I'm still deciding I know many of
you have reached out you want to go on
it's unique experience it's very no one
will ever do it I mean it's truly cool
and I like it it's a lot of fun I don't
know if I'm gonna do it but I might as
always live dates okay I want you
[ __ ] to come buy some tickets tag
your friends like this is like
Shakeology side splitters in Tampa tober
17 to xx hyenas Fort Worth Texas
November 14th through the 16th Vermont
Comedy Club November 21st through the
23rd stress factory breed I'm going off
quito and Vermont I'll tell you that
much I am [ __ ] I just want to go to
Vermont I just I just drink maple syrup
shrestha and it's not even good it's
like the sugar syrup is better the
antrum I'm is better the corn syrups
better but whatever but it's fun to have
the you know stress factory Bridgeport
December 5th through the 7th in
Connecticut comedy connection Providence
Rhode Island December 13th and 14th
McGoo bees timonium Marilyn god I love
Mugu bees but that town is not fun it's
a rest stop that became a town January
9th through the 11th I'm also I'm a
having a crab cake there zany's Chicago
February 5th through the 8th this is a
long run 56 she's still going oh my god
she's singing now what is she singing I
don't know let's sing with her
be juicy juicy I eat that lunch I he
like the booty booty he liked it plump
got it is a doozy
now if you can see it from the front
you're gonna see it from the back back
back back
well put my true religion mama I put my
ass in your face now come out Z knees in
Chicago House economy Bloomington
Minnesota April 9th to the 11th how's
the comedy Phoenix Arizona May 7th
through the 9th comic strip Edmonton
June 18th through the 20th and the big
one announcing I'm announcing this this
is the big one headlining Caroline's
comedy club in New York City March 12th
to March 14th five shows Thursday Friday
Saturday March 12th through the 14th
Caroline's in New York City it's gonna
be a big show I'm gonna [ __ ] get
great people to open for me I'm gonna
put great guest spots on that show man
it's gonna be [ __ ] killer that show I
can promise you is gonna be great so
those are the live dates they are all on
Instagram they're all on Tim Dylan
comedy comm with links to ticket pages
I'm also coming to Edmonton I think I
said that comic strip in Edmonton Canada
Edmonton Alberta June 18th through the
20th so I'm after on the road get
tickets shows a lot of fun I've knew 45
minutes of material and I also you know
me I [ __ ] talk about all kinds of
[ __ ] onstage it's not it's not only
material trust me to the uh you know to
the consternation of some of my
representatives like we really can't
submit this tape where you just go off
about the Illuminati for ten minutes I'm
like but the audience is laughing
they're like yeah but you're you're
directly referencing networks and I'm
like you know this isn't I'm like well
yeah I understand that I think in one
tape I submitted I said a carpool
karaoke would only be funny if they get
into an accident so they were like yeah
we don't we shouldn't really submit this
you said Jimmy Fallon was chained to his
desk so we didn't bite someone's Ted
I'm like is that not how that show works
I mean I imagine that's how that show
works he's he's injected with things
he's chained in the desk am I wrong I
might is that not how late-night
television works is he doing this of his
own free will I mean I know he's making
money but after a while guess who's on I
found tonight Billy Eilish our girl with
a leg brace I wonder what happened I
wonder what happened Billy did you trip
at Bohemian Grove I know she's not a
saint and she probably just [ __ ]
boring or maybe she is what the [ __ ] do
I know I don't care anymore nobody's
given me anything the [ __ ] am i
protecting I'd sit now at her if she
bought me lunch she's gotta buy me lunch
[ __ ] in arenas I'm Hawking CBD sit
down explain to me why you're good
explain to me why this is good I'm Billy
yeah you want me to be really I'm gonna
be really honest right now everybody
riding but you I don't you are yeah I
wanna sacrifice a baby
defiling innocence is the highest
sacrament in the religion I am in death
that's Billy and you know what are you
gonna do we're gonna have a lot of fun
if you come out to the shows and
patreon.com the Tim Dylan show we got a
lot goin on we're gonna get some guests
on the page
we're not really doing a ton of guests
on the main program we do we will do the
big guys will do like Coco Diaz and
stuff but we're not doing like you know
people that are not worthy of get in
this time because you have a lot of fun
with this time but on patreon we're
gonna do some guests
some may be deeper interviews with
people so if you're interested in that
stuff patreon $5 a month is a way to do
it 20 you could be a Rothschild member
we appreciate that longer versions of
the videos we did fun video we did that
up the video that we did I think it's at
one hundred and sixteen thousand or
something views on Twitter if you see
those things and you can share them it's
great if you do if you're in a position
where you can't for whatever reason
they're there to whatever then find then
create an alt account and share them
from there okay but it's good you know
because I'm not I'm not waiting for blue
check mark people to share the videos
but they are funny man it's a type of
comedy there's not a lot of people doing
what we're doing out there they're just
there's not and I'm not saying that to
be like wow and by the way that shocks
me because what we're doing isn't that
big of a deal and it shocks me that more
people don't put together but I think a
lot of people just maybe are afraid of
rubbing people the wrong way about doing
some of these things but there are some
people that are doing funny sketches
joke quiz Allah does funny sketches
Meigs stalter Megan stalter does funny
sketches Conor O'Malley does funny
they're all funny and all those people
might hate my guts I don't care but I
think their sketches are good you know
they probably think I'm like David Duke
you know because I think so I think
Shane Gillis shouldn't be roasted in the
Town Square but maybe they I don't know
how they feel about it
I'm just saying those are three very
funny people it's not my business how
everyone feels
I don't care none of it matters my uncle
lived in Ridgewood New Jersey had a
great cheese place and there was a great
fish cheese spread if the guy making
that spread was a Nazi I don't care and
that's a bad example
no the Shane's not a Nazi and S&L is
nowhere near as good as that fish Brett
but do you get what I'm sick I don't
care what you believe in your home the
reason we have the country set up the
way does is to crush your beliefs anyway
don't the word out to [ __ ] up the only
word that's kept out in this goddamn
countries about beachbody.com
and Shakeology to buy